hahaha
it's that time of year when vacant
storefronts temporarily transform into
Spirit Halloweens that spooky seasonal
retailer that seemingly everywhere
overnight for Spirit Halloween a pop-up
lease is ideal because then they're only
paying for space when they truly need it
guess what's finally open the spirit
store happy day happy day and with
consumers expected to spend a record
amount for the holiday spirit Halloween
has opened more stores than ever this
year so how does Spirit Halloween
capitalize on abandoned spaces in local
markets and how does it manage to
transform those vacant storefronts so
quickly this is the economics of Spirit
Halloween
the first Spirit Halloween popped up in
1983 in Castro Valley California it was
an extension of founder Joe marver's
women's clothing store traditionally
October is a very slow month for for
retail General and there was a Halloween
store in the Strip Center that he
operated and he saw that there were
lines coming out so I said that might be
a good idea so with that he turned his
Boutique into a Halloween store and kind
of the rest is history in 1999 marver
sold the company to Spencer Gifts that
mall store known for gag gifts and it's
built a reputation among those who love
Halloween
so much so that more than 2 000 fans
showed up to the July grand opening of
the flagship store in New Jersey
but the retailer is hoping last minute
Shoppers come through the door too one
of the advantages is that they're
everywhere so if someone has forgotten
about Halloween and needs to get a last
minute costume and can't wait for it to
be delivered after it was bought online
then they can just pop into a Spirit
Halloween while Shoppers can buy
Halloween fair on the company's website
at any time none of its physical
locations operate year round Spirit
Halloween prefers a temporary lease
because it is not a year-round business
so for them they want to save as much
money as possible on real estate and so
it makes much more sense for them to
take space temporarily Spirit Halloween
says convincing landlords wasn't easy at
first years ago when we sat down with
landlords and said hey we've got this
idea we've got a pop-up Halloween store
or we're going to come for two months we
get the look of uh you know really what
you know why why would I bother with
that though landlords tend to prefer
long-term leases pop-ups can be an
alternative to space
in the Years following the Great
Recession as retail vacancies increase
landlords found that pop-ups were an
effective way of filling space that had
been vacant for a long time because of
course some revenue is better than no
Revenue
and to make temporary leases more
attractive to landlords the company ads
kickout Clauses if they find a space
where they want to open but the landlord
finds another tenant who's willing to
sign a long-term lease before a certain
day maybe it's middle of June for
example then Spirit Halloween loses that
space
for Spirit Halloween finding real estate
is a year-round business when stores
shut down for one season the company is
already talking to landlords about the
next
big spaces are key up to 50 000 square
feet often where big box retailers used
to live those storefronts are often in
shopping centers or strip malls but can
also be Standalone and signing the lease
is just the beginning the retailer says
setting up the stores is another
logistical challenge I mean literally we
are starting from scratch in every
single store we inherit an empty
location and we have to bring in not
only all the merchandise but all the
fixturing we have to hire the entire
staff according to the National Retail
Federation spending on Halloween is
expected to hit a record 10.6 billion
dollars in 2022 on average customers are
planning to spend 100 each on costumes
Decor candy and cards this year and 36
percent of customers plan to shop at
specialty stores like Spirit Halloween
and with 1450 stores across the U.S and
Canada it's one of the most ubiquitous
it's a sign of fall it's kind of like
you get your pumpkin spice latte you're
back to school you see Spirit Halloween
open up in shopping centers on your
drive to work one of its biggest
competitors Party City's pop-up Branch
Halloween City operated 275 stores in
2019 and scaled back during the pandemic
Spirit Halloween's pop-up model has
become such a fixture of the Season that
it's inspired a new movie pop-up
Halloween store in a creepy lot awesome
and countless internet memes people joke
about how quickly the company moves in
after something else shuts down we kind
of enjoy the meme value of spirit we
bring life and we bring joy we bring
energy we bring a whole you know new
reason and so
the main value of spirit is recognition
of of of that value that's part of the
reason Spirit Halloween decided to open
all of its planned 1400 stores in 2020
while competitors opened fewer during
the kova 19 pandemic in 2021 the
companies that had experienced product
delays and increased shipping costs last
year we didn't realize the the magnitude
of the issue with the supply chain until
April and when suddenly everything dried
up by the end of the season we had
received all of our merchandise but it
was it was through some really difficult
cartwheels and somersaults the retailer
says all of its locations are fully
stocked this year
the company wants to be the beginning of
the holiday coming to a Spirit Halloween
is an event it's something that the fans
really look forward to it's almost like
the new season and when we come that's
when Halloween starts and for landlords
with empty storefronts Spirit Halloween
continues to temporarily bring life back
to those abandoned spaces
thank you